Andrea Savage is one of comedies
funniest ladies that's right I'm one of
these guys who thinks women are just as
funny as men and if you don't believe me
try telling that to some of the queens
of comedy like Maria Menounos and Heidi
Klum Jason seriously what do you want me
to say that my husband makes way more
money than you that he's smarter or more
clever my life is better with him and in
any moment even in the best moments of
our relationship I don't know what you
want me just to know why would I want
you to say those things that makes no
sense
I never say them you may need I mean he
pleases me in ways that you never were
able to okay all right I doubt that I
doubt that he really yeah real by the
way that I really I didn't tell you some
ways but I don't know if that's the kind
of thing is that something that I could
do it that I can learn that this is just
the actual quick hand of the equipment I
think it's just the confidence it's hard
to say shall we what is he